the Joe Rogan experience so that's it
what are we talking about what do you
whatever you want to talk about fella
right here you got some news yeah so I
figured I know there's a lot of there's
probably some cool fans it'll probably
tune in to this specifically to hear
some news yeah so rather than being a
dick and waiting to the end to tell them
I probably should probably tell them up
front are you like softening in your age
no not at all I just care I just I care
about that as long as things have taken
for us because we're a very difficult
band we're very stubborn and we're you
know we're kind of ignorant to what goes
on in the rest of the world and so
people like you guys come on guys and
you know I mean to their credit like we
did the whole Betamax thing didn't work
for us and neither did laserdisc so we
have this new thing called digital media
and streaming we're gonna try it out you
get extremes there's a thing it's a new
thing streaming so you can just say yeah
I like Spotify that kind of deal yeah
yeah it's brand-new
yeah like which is on your phone or
something to us it's brand-new
what are you doing with it we're gonna
put some songs on it Wow so you can
listen yeah well you not even like
plugged in any incorrect so here's what
I'm gonna do now because this is by the
time this actually airs this will have
already happened but you're filming me
doing it right you're gonna upload sweet
I'm gonna do a thing letting everybody
know I'm a Tweaker
do you have it prepared and everything
not really so you you're doing this
because you're fans which are very rabid
you have rabid fans the tool fans are
particularly enthusiastic they're pretty
they're pretty aggressive they're yeah
well that's cuz you guys are awesome
thank you you [ __ ] up made an awesome
band got some radical fans okay so Wow
when if you release this podcast the
idea was that if you set it on the
podcast without letting them know first
yeah
they deserve to hear first they've been
very patient with us very patient so
this Friday August 2nd don't dump down
the catalogue the whole catalog catalog
goes up on Napster on Napster with
Napster I've heard that's great that
bars guys really upset about it yes you
should
talk to Lars about this he's got a whole
thing he's gonna try to figure out
figure out it and undermine them yeah
he's gonna stop him strike head look
goes up on all digital and stream he's
doing this on his phone right now I was
we're talking dreaming so up until this
time Matt's you never have had anything
up and available no you're like what's
his name
Garth Brooks yeah he doesn't have
anything up either no comment
Garth Brooks doesn't he he just wants
his but it's kind of like a good
artistic choice he doesn't want his
stuff to be broken up into songs he
wants you to download or to buy his
entire CD because he feels like there's
a correct order for his songs he says
that that's what he says yeah we tried
to which I had that move for him people
feel like no no we want you to hear our
whole album as you know in sequence and
people like like you play them live like
oh yeah we'd never played I'm not the
guy that said no no we wanted you to
yeah that's because that would be an
absolute lie yeah yeah Garth Brooks has
some weird things of course Garth Brooks
is being currently harassed and away we
go by Tom Segura so what's up they go up
there beautiful it's out there in the
ether it's out there so why have you
guys not had anything on streaming up
until this moment by yeah no yeah I love
my brothers I'm just gonna take the
fifth on that one okay so there was some
sort of internal discussion or or no
discussion or no discussion yeah just
the the typical tool time of like what
was there was a meeting mm-hmm well
again this is what you get with great
artists you don't get great artists who
are also the best promoters correct the
ones who are the best promoters usually
they're not the best artist who's also
we're gonna do today yeah you doing
nothing is this like one of them
late night things reselling knives oh
yeah extra yeah I do want a knife
because I sell them you also have some
old stock in beta
yeah and samurai swords yeah no I'm
gonna announced
name of the new album you like that yeah
you're doing on your phone first fear of
a black planet and River black planet
sound fear in a queue um white guy
spinning on an album called the black
plan which I can really go over well and
yeah those are the least woke thing you
could do money would buy the first copy
fear inoculum is the name of the album
fear inoculum who'd you say we buy the
first album I'm not gonna say that again
I didn't hear what you said
I might have said cowboy journey cowboy
Cerrone yeah why would you say that
I don't know cuz he swears that cowboy
hat and I just assumed that he's got a
lot of black friends I think you're out
of line I'm totally trans with all these
black and now he's gonna be mad at me
now I got apologize you're joking you
probably want to hear this it's probably
too busy jumping a jet ski over a bridge
just jealous above his hat so August 30
you in the maths you got some money you
got a hat of your own yes I do it's like
a Sinatra hat it's if you weren't so
cool that would be a douchebag hat
that's them Breaking Bad yeah right
there I like it I like it on you I like
it on you it looks good on you it does
there's there's things that people like
you could pull off one of those buckskin
pioneer jackets with the fray you could
pull you know they have that what does
that stuff call the tassels that hang
down from the size of the chair no way
we go in a way we go yeah put it on
Instagram as well
we've just I just put it under your
mattress we'll get it on Twitter in a
minute cuz I'm good more important
things now people will stop [ __ ] up
they'll leave you long